okay we're gonna talk about blood-borne
now okay so they showed a bunch of new
gameplay footage at Gamescom yeah I we
want to take a look at it again because
it looks really good
what do you guys think what do you guys
make of this game you know uh well I
mean Dark Souls I mean that's Dark Souls
is my favorite game of the generation we
have just climbed out of and clawed our
way free of the PlayStation 3 and Xbox
360 and I see some comments on the on
the video and I'm the other stuff saying
you know it's just Dark Souls blah blah
blah and I don't I don't know that that
really has to be a bad thing you know
No so I I really like the way it looks I
really love the art style I mean it
doesn't but I look at it it looks like
it okay so it plays a little bit like
you know somewhat like Dark Souls it
uses some of the same basic mechanics
but this world doesn't really look like
it feels like Dark Souls and that's a
big part of the Dark Souls experience as
the feel so now you've got blood-borne
and it looks like this Victorian era you
know Jack the Ripper type atmosphere
you're talking to loosely about the
environmental design because I look at
this and then looks like the movement it
looks like you know the the UI like the
enemies sort of the spacing the lighting
mmm it feels very much like Dark Souls
and it's really you know from software's
one of the developers on it I think
they're working with another team that
is escaping my brain IAM right now but
you're right this is not a world like
this is a very distinct environment yeah
yeah they showed you know crowds of like
enemies walking around they seem to be
doing their own thing like I mean I
haven't have never played really Dark
Souls but if there's anything I would
say about that is bosses seem pretty I
don't know generic a little bit as
complete like compared to like bosses
here or you know they're they're moving
around they're you know well I guess
real like we're like three into this
solo series is a war so you know it's I
guess the the thing that will always pop
at is the change of environment have a
plug touched on like how much technology
is gonna play a part here because
obviously like weapons like guns range
weapons that like changes up to combat
quite a lot we're seeing a lot
hand on hand here or like melee fighting
have they talked or have you have you
seen anything Kevin that like makes it
look different in terms of well they
talked about how how you're gonna
replenish health if you're more
aggressive but if you really get in
there and start chopping up enemies and
in in combo lands then you're gonna
you're gonna be able to start like
earning health by doing that I think
that the intention is to is to get you
to focus on a more aggressive style of
play
then maybe Dark Souls would offer that
will be interesting for me because my
dark because as a you know I go into
Dark Souls stamina heavy like I'm all
about taking as many hits as I can
before I can get in my own you know my
own chance so I'm kind of water you want
to heal the block yeah so I'm curious is
this gonna is this gonna have me a
little more active is it's gonna have me
having to be a little more agile I don't
know but then you look at stuff like
it's like oh he rolls the same way oh he
you know he moves the same way attacks
the same way cloth moves the same way so
and of course I look at that bit there's
a bit where he picks up the torch in the
darkness and and it looks like oh you
need the torch for the darkness but we
heard that already about Dark Souls 2
and that didn't really come to fruition
look at that dude but the enemy design
is so good are they gonna have guns as
well I hope enemies close to just like a
brick you're not be as big as out there
you all you need a break you need is a
brick grab his junk
what could knock him on his butt we can
only hope when's this bad boy out again
sometime 2015 so that's an interesting
move to the leap in and the jump Kevin
wasn't Garret oh right yeah I'm sorry
I'm watching the footage I'm watching
the foot a Dean oh yeah the old giant
axe spin attack so yeah certainly you
know creature design always the strength
of the Dark Souls or of the souls series
that seems to be represented so my genre
now right it really is I mean I feel
like we have to have a few more
imitators but I don't know we had one we
have imitators now Wes so you put wet in
there as well wet well yeah that is
definitely the most Souls II and guess I
just haven't talked about it I don't
think anyone's in that game in the place
we
got that other game that looks very
Souls II coming up and now I suddenly
forgotten the name of it Oh wet to know
whether blades something wet harder
somebody out there knows what I'm
talking about suddenly forgotten the
name of hell what it's not no it's not
all right
but it's not wet I am looking forward to
hell blade though because Ninja Theory
thumbs up I'm looking forward to them
renaming that heavenly sword - they've
come right out it's not a slave idli no
that's actually like the fact that
they're not like they're not resting on
their barrels high peace for the better
marketing hype alright that's a look at
blood-borne in action folks